[Musique]
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre à qui j'adresse au nom de mon
groupe la bienvenue au sein de notre
haute assemblée la feuille de route qui
a été fixé par le président de la
république marquent le retour de la
réforme des retraites il n'y aura pas
d'abandon at-il précisé dans la presse
régionale vous-même avait affirmé
vouloir régler ce dossier
à court terme cette réforme a été
suspendu parce qu'elle n'apparaissait
plus prioritaires alors que prions la
république cherchait la concorde
nationale face à la colite 19
ces appels à l'unité nationale se
fracasse sur la reprise ce projet
repoussé par une large majorité de nos
concitoyens vous souffler sur les
braises de la division avec s'appuie sur
ce dogme libéral selon lequel
travaillait plus durant sa vie durant la
semaine
c'est la seule voie pour l' équilibre
financier
pourtant les sommes considérables dégagé
pour venir en aide aux entreprises
montrent que les richesses sont là et
peuvent satisfaire l'intérêt général
monsieur le premier ministre la nation
garantit à tous notamment à l'enfant à
la mère et aux vieux travailleurs la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et le loup et les
loisirs
tout être humain en raison de son âge se
trouve dans l'incapacité de travailler a
le droit d'obtenir de la collectivité
des moyens convenables d'existence le
gaullisme social dont vous vous
revendiquez monsieur le premier ministre
se fonde sur ces mots de l'alinéa
l'alinéa 11 du préambule de la
constitution de 46 toujours en vigueur
aujourd'hui
est-ce conciliables selon vous avec la
déferlante ribéral porté par mais chez
makro allez vous mais sur le premier
ministre oui ou non
renoncer à cette réforme des retraites
dont l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
ne veulent plus entendre parler
aujourd'hui pour vous répondre la parole
qu'à monsieur le premier ministre vous
avez la parole monsieur le président
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je ne sais pas qui ne veut plus entendre
parler de la réforme des retraites mais
refusé de parler des retraites refusé de
parler des retraites
lorsque dès avant la crise mais a
fortiori avec la survenance de cette
dernière
l' équilibre des comptes et donc la
sauvegarde du système actuel se trouve
compromise serait irresponsable il
responsable madame il reste au ca je
suis comme vous je n'en doute pas
extrêmement attaché au préambule de la
constitution de 1946 et à la conduite
des politiques sociales comme ferment de
notre pacte républicain bien qui peut
dire ici de façon plus structurelle que
notre système de retraite que je connais
bien sûr lequel j'ai travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années est juste il ne l'est
pas il ne l'est pas alors je vais vous
dire madame ce que je compte faire je
vais vous dire ce que je compte faire
premièrement je vais ouvrir le dialogue
toutes les organisations syndicales
viendront discuter avec moi et c'est
heureux que nous ne soyons pas d'accord
avec certaines d'entre elles
peut-être nous verrons bien 1 nous
rouvrons le dialogue et nous nous
mettons d'accord sur une méthode et un
calendrier
deuxièmement je traiterai j'aborderai la
question des retraites dans un cadre
global la réforme de l'assurance chômage
elle aussi indispensable mais elle aussi
impacté par la crise et il serait
déraisonnable de ne pas tenir compte de
cet élément nouveau la relance qui sur
bien des sujets impact des
considérations qui intéresse les
partenaires sociaux la dépendance moult
fois reporté et que le président de la
république m'a demandé avec mon
gouvernement de conduire
nous allons avoir une approche globale
de ces sujets et s'agissant des
retraites
je proposerai aux partenaires sociaux de
très clairement distingué la réforme que
les spécialistes appellent systémique
la réforme de structure vers un système
plus juste et plus égalitaire pour nos
concitoyens sur lesquels la concertation
va reprendre et ensuite la question de
l' équilibre du système actuel sur
lesquels je demanderai et également aux
partenaires sociaux
madame de me faire leurs propositions
alors même
j'appelle votre attention et celle du
sénat que le système paritaire existence
sur les complémentaires agirc arrco lui
même pour les mêmes raisons confronté à
une menace de déséquilibre les conduira
nécessairement à reprendre le chemin de
la négociation
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix madame la
présidente que de sauvegarder notre
système de protection sociale
même la présidente pour quelques
secondes président très et très
rapidement monsieur premier mini
je vous le redis est et avec force cette
réforme des retraites est irresponsable
et elle est injuste nous le savons déjà
il y a eu moult rencontres avec les les
syndicats y compris aujourd'hui le medef
se dit opposé à cette réforme
donc nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler mais je dois dire monsieur le
premier ministre que vous êtes là sur un
très mauvais chemin bien
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
patrick kanner pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre au début du précédent
quinquennat j'avais adressé mes voeux de
réussite républicaine à votre
prédécesseur
j'aurais tendance à voir le même message
pour vous mais entre temps il faut bien
le reconnaître un fossé s'est creusé
entre la politique menée par le
président de la république et les
français ce dernier a déclaré sa volonté
de tracer un nouveau chemin cette
nouvelle orientation les français la
souhaite je vous le confirme ils l'ont
montré en choisissant leur mère et en
sanctionnant lourdement les candidats de
la majorité présidentielle aux élections
municipales
ce nouveau chemin est indispensable pour
affronter la crise économique et sociale
qui est déjà là et qui va s'amplifier et
permettez moi de penser en premier lieu
à la jeunesse de france pour qu'il faut
imaginer très vite un plan d'urgence
sociale malheureusement la composition
de votre gouvernement ainsi que vos
premières déclarations me font craindre
nous font craindre que plutôt que d'être
l'incarnation du renouveau vous ne soyez
finalement que l'homme du passif
monsieur près ministre ce passif est
lourd réforme des retraites tentative de
privatisation da dp loi immigration
assurance-chômage dégradé suppression
lisf crise et gilet jaune je pourrais
continuer mais le temps nous est compté
un bilan qui fragmentent d'autres pays
dans un climat anxiogène les plus
faibles devraient être mieux protégés
particulièrement ce moment et vous devez
rassembler les français mais je prie
ministre les protéger les accompagner
face à la crise
amorti certes provisoirement par le
ruissellement de la dette publique mais
vous fait payer par tous ma question est
simple monsieur le premier ministre
en clair allez vous changer radicalement
de la politique menée depuis trois ans
allez vous choisir entre les jours
heureux de l'état providence où les
jours désastreux de l'état pénitence
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président monsieur
président caennais repart mais n'était
pas d'abord de vous présenter mes
félicitations pour le caractère poétique
de vos propos que nous avons tous
apprécié surtout les beaux mais je le
cren veut être un peu déconnectés de la
réalité
je voulais 10 à la faveur de ma première
intervention le nouveau chemin annoncé
par le président de la république
s'inscrit dans un nouveau contexte nous
devons faire face
je vous le répète président à une crise
qui s'annonce exceptionnel devant nous
pour autant renoncer un certain nombre
de réformes qui ont été entreprises qui
peuvent se discuter qui devront je le
répète être réorientés dans le cadre de
cette crise et de ce contexte nouveau
sûrement mais me semble-t-il rien ne
serait pire que de faire face à la crise
qui s'annonce en retournant à une forme
d'immobilisme
je l' ai déjà dit et je les assume
mon gouvernement est un gouvernement de
combat dans un contexte extrêmement
dégradée
j'entends bien puisque vous avez parlé
monsieur le président de la dette
publique des comptes publics j'apprends
votre vif attachement à ces notions
j'entends bien j'entends bien que nous
tirions les conséquences du passé à
savoir que la lutte contre la crise qui
est déjà là ne soient pas suivis parce
qu'elle en train de nous y sommes
effectivement une dégradation des
comptes sociaux que le président
marseille a déjà évoqué et des comptes
publics en général ne soit pas suivie
dans deux ans dans trois ans par un
matraquage fiscal que d'autres majorités
ont largement déployée pour cela pour
cela nous devons d'abord c'est
l'occasion de le rappeler devant cette
assemblée gérer cette crise
internationale dans un cadre européen
plus que pour la crise de 2008-2010 que
j'ai bien connu il faut que l'europe
s'engage et ne fasse pas porter aux
seuls états et donc in fine et à leurs
contribuables
les mesures réparatrices et
reconstructive que cette crise appelle
il faut aussi que nous puissions isolé
et gérer dans la durée la dette qu'on
appelle des goûts vide que cette crise
est immanquablement va créer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président je suis ici à la tête d'un
gouvernement à la fois renouvelée avec
des visages nouveaux
incarnant également la continuité très
peu mais ils sont beaux
incarnant la continuité pour
d'arrache-pied préserver les français
tout en continuant de moderniser la
france sur le président kader monsieur
le premier ministre vous vous dites
gaulliste social certes encartés sont
utiles aujourd'hui dans un parti
centriste mais j'aurais aimé d'un
gaulliste social entendre des mots
redistribution pouvoir d'achat service
public planification
je pense que se reparler y compris une
partie de la droite de l'hémicycle
ce n'a pas été le cas et votre réponse
de me rassure pas sur votre capacité à
gérer l'urgence sanitaire social et
économique qui nous attend dans ce pays
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à notre collègue alain
fouché pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre à mon tour au nom
du groupe je voudrais saluer votre
arrivée avec un autre gouvernement dans
notre assemblée
je m'adresse à monsieur le garde des
sceaux monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez déclaré vouloir améliorer la
justice de notre pays
vouloir garder le meilleur échange est
le pire
le chantier qui vous attend est vaste et
français ont perdu confiance dans cette
institution elle inspirerait même de la
défiance à près de la moitié de nos
concitoyens selon un très récent sondage
de n'avance rien qu'il est long et
difficile aujourd'hui d'obtenir justice
face à des procédures complexes et
coûteuses au manque criant de moyens
humains et matériels
nos concitoyens sont trop nombreux avoir
renoncé à faire valoir leurs droits les
français ont parfois le sentiment
persistant que l'institution judiciaire
de notre pays est forte avec les faibles
et faible avec les forts l'arbitraire la
plus grande menace qui pèse sur la
justice et ce départ et sont le meilleur
rempart contre cela réside dans le
respect des formes et des procédures
la loi date est la même pour tous soit
qu'elle protège soit qu'elle punisse
vous l'avez dit monsieur le garde des
sceaux la justice de son nid dans la rue
ils jouent les réseaux sociaux ni dans
les médias
il s'agit d'une des missions
essentielles de l'état c'est aussi l'une
des des institutions les plus
nécessaires à notre démocratie
elle doit être dotée de moyens à la
hauteur de sa mission
les français ont besoin d'une justice
efficace rapide et accessible
monsieur le ministre avec l'expérience
qui est la vôtre vous avez déclaré qu'il
fallait revoir l'institution judiciaire
de a à z
pouvez vous nous dire quelles sont les
mesures prioritaires que vous comptez
prendre pour vous répondre la parole est
au garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice monsieur dupont moretti vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
le sénateur quelques secondes brève dans
ces courtes minutes
2 je crois dire d'abord ma ma fierté mon
émotion la confiance de monsieur
président de la république monsieur le
premier ministre
faut que je mesure ici à cet instant
l'humilité de la tâche qui est la mienne
et je voudrais vous dire que la
connaissance que j'ai de la justice et
une connaissance empirique
hier j'ai dit charnel laisse moi laissez
moi s'il vous plaît à prendre mon
administration se faire j'aurais
naturellement besoin de tous les
parlementaires de la majorité et je ne
suis pas un politique comme de
l'opposition
il est possible voyez vous de faire
évoluer la procédure pénale de a à z ou
de ac mais peu importe de a à z en
quelques mois c'est compliqué mais tout
de même ça c'est que lors de la
commission denquête parlementaires
d'août
des parlementaires de toutes
sensibilités ont réussi parce que la
justice nous l'avons au coeur ont réussi
à transcender tous les clivages et ont
proposé 80 de modification de notre
procédure pénale
je m'appuierai d'ailleurs sur ce travail
ce que je veux par exemple c'est une
justice de proximité
bien sûr il ya le budget mais il y a
aussi les hommes l'humanité ça ne coûte
rien le doute
non mais les hommes au sens ne ne me
prenez pas sur ce terrain les hommes au
sens chez les hommes et les femmes
les vins et les hommes sané sané le
signe de rien madame pardon alors je
voudrais terminer mon propos
il ya par exemple des choses toutes
simples remettre au coeur de la justice
la présomption d'innocence éviter des
enquêtes préliminaires qui ne sont plus
préliminaire et qui s'éternise sans
aucun contradictoires
quelque chose de très simples voyous et
ça ça n'est pas une question budgétaire
les victimes qui parfois ne sont même
pas reçu par le juge d'instruction ça
c'est très simple à mettre en oeuvre
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé aux procureurs
généraux qu'ils viennent me voir pour
qu'on parle de cela j'ai lu également
qu'un syndicat de magistrats du siège
disait alors déjà on va donner des
ordres
alors si nous ne faisons pas avec les
procureurs généraux nous le ferons avec
vous c'est tout simple de demander à une
victime devenir une justice plus proche
plus humaine
je suis allé hier en détention nissan a
partagé le garde des sceaux aura un tout
petit peu achevée vous est pris par le
temps vous bénéficiez de aller c'est
parce que c'est la première fois à les
[Applaudissements]
accorder mois le bénéfice de
l'inexpérience au cou monsieur couchez
vous avez quelques secondes
non
appuyez sur le bouton et moi monsieur le
président le ministre a donné un certain
nombre d'éléments qui n'est pas pareil
que des clercs et intéressant tu dis moi
je fais partie de la profession d'avocat
je connais les choses donc il ya des
choses qui sont intéressants qui à tour
proposé qui ne fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui voilà alors la parole est au
président philippe bas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président est d'abord
au nom de mon groupe je veux à mon tour
souhaité la bienvenue au sénat au
nouveau gouvernement
ma question est aussi pour le garde des
sceaux monsieur le ministre je vais
changer ma question parce que monsieur
foucher vient de vous interroger et je
ne suis pas satisfait de votre réponse
vous donner une image incontestablement
forte de la justice ce faisant vous
créez une énorme attente
vous avez dressé hier un constat un
constat sans doute sévère mais un
constat que je crois lucide ce constat
nous l'avons fait nous aussi dans notre
rapport de 2010 7 5 ans pour sauver la
justice et justiciables qui piétine aux
portes des tribunaux les magistrats et
des greffés privé du moyen de faire
correctement leur travail des avocats
qui se comptent par milliers en
situation de précarité une
administration pénitentiaire à bout de
souffle des détenus qui sortent de
prison sans être préparé à la
réinsertion et qui vont rejoindre les
gros contingent de récidivistes et face
à cela monsieur le ministre vous n'avez
pas pu accepter cette fonction sans
avoir reçu de fortes assurances du
premier ministre et du président de la
république car le redressement de la
justice est à l'ordre du jour et je
voudrais vraiment savoir plus
précisément que dans votre réponse à
monsieur foucher ce que vous entendez
faire pour faire face à ce défi
essentiel du service public de la
justice
la parole est à monsieur le le garde des
sceaux monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président vous me demandez
donc à moi ce que m'a dit monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre m'a dit que la loi de
programmation serait pour vous quant à
vos travaux vous allez être satisfait je
l'espère ils sont d'ores et déjà sur mon
bureau je vous fais la confession que je
n'ai pas encore eu le temps de tout lire
mais je le ferai vous serez bien
évidemment conviés nous parlerons
ensemble de cela j'envisage très
prochainement de recevoir tous les
présidents eux deux groupes jeudi tous
les présidents de groupe g comment vous
le dire autrement peu ce besoin de vous
j'ai besoin de vos conseils
j'ai besoin de votre contradictoires et
nous avons besoin ensemble de faire
évoluer la justice de notre pays
nous sommes le pays dans le rang des
pays les plus condamnés nous occupons le
triste douzième rang sur 47 pays
la plupart des condamnations étant
intervenu pour un procès qui n'est pas
un procès équitable
et cela ce n'est pas une question de
budget pour vous répondre la parole est
au président pas pour vous répondre
pour vous répliqué au président philippe
bas
monsieur le ministre vous allez nous
recevoir et nous nous allons vous
auditionné après la déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
nous sommes pressés de vous entendre
nous voulons rentrer dans les détails
vous avez mis la barre haut et même
peut-être très haut c'est la bonne
altitude et maintenant à vous de la
franchir
les élections municipales ont montré ce
que nous rendions nous redoutions tous
une poussée de l'entrisme
communautariste dans les listes
municipales dans le val d'oise cousin
ville est revenu un candidat dont le
profil interroge même les services de
renseignement à garges-lès-gonesse la
ville a failli tomber entre les mains
d'une fondateur du ccf à strasbourg le
hidjab pire cymbales de
l'infériorisation de l'enfermement de la
négation du corps de la femme a fait son
entrée au conseil municipal
dans ces villes comme dans d'autres
l'islam politique trace son chemin
face à un manque cruel de courage pour y
faire obstacle
et préserver notre unité et les valeurs
de la république
le constat de ces élections municipales
et celui du début
malheureusement d'un morcellement
inquiétant que personne ne peut nier
il ya quelques mois le président la
république avait indiqué vouloir
combattre le séparatisme islamiste à ce
jour nous n'avons toujours ni ligne
directrice ni cap clair vous lutter
efficacement contre ces dérives qui mène
à la fracture de notre pays à ce sujet
comme sur tant d'autres il vous
appartient monsieur munissent de ne pas
être spectateur je veux revenir monsieur
le ministre sur certains de vos propos à
ce sujet et qui m'interroge en effet il
y a quelques années vous aviez parlé de
laïcité punitive
or la laïcité ne doit jamais être actée
adjectiv et dit faire l'objet d'un
commandement
par ailleurs vous aviez suggéré l'idée
d'un nouveau concordat avec l'islam qui
remettrait gravement en cause les
principes mêmes de la loi de 1905 et qui
dénaturerait la conception largement
partagé par les français de la laïcité
monsieur le ministre s'engager pour la
france c'est accepter de se faire
détester par une minorité gesticulante
au profit d'une majorité qui ne
demandent qu'une chose vivre en paix et
en harmonie dans cette france
intégratrice et tolérante
quel chemin monsieur le ministre allez
vous prendre quelle réponse allez vous
apporter à cet islam politique qui tenta
assignée à résidence et à exclure de la
république
une partie de nos concitoyens en profite
d'une âme religieuse pour vous répondre
la parole et au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur gérald darmanin la parole
monsieur me dit monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
le président de la république et
premiers ministres m'ont fait confiance
avec marlène schiappa qui travaille
auprès de moi pour continuer à rétablir
la sécurité des français pour
accompagner bien sûr le travail des
services publics à intermédiaire du
corps préfectoral pour rendre respect
écoute à nos forces de l'ordre mais
également bien sûr pour lutter contre ce
que le président de la république dans
son discours a qualifié de séparatisme
et oui l'islam politique est un ennemi
mortel pour la république
oui il faut combattre toute forme de
communautarisme mais ils ne semblent
madame que les mises intérieure est
également le ministre des cultes et
qu'en france est citée ne veut pas dire
la négation de cette liberté des cultes
et il me semble que vos propos sont un
petit peu caricatural tout en étant très
ferme caricaturaux
je veux que vous suivez
madame mon grand-père prier allah et
porter l'uniforme de la république
il m'a semblé que bien des tirailleurs
algériens et bien des supplétifs ont par
ailleurs tout en priant pour leur
religion défendu les valeurs de la
république
alors oui oui à la liberté de culte non
à la caricature non à l'islamisme
politique où il ya des français quelle
que soit leur couleur de peau quelle que
soit leur religion
madame si nous pouvions discuter de ce
qui fait nation c'est-à-dire la
marseillaise la culture la langue notre
drapeau et pato vaisseau des caricatures
vous avez eu la gentillesse de me citer
vous avez la gentillesse le site et vous
verrez madame que je suis très fier de
l'assimilation française mon premier
prénom à gérald mon deuxième prénom et
moussa et grâce au président de la
république et grâce à ceux qui m'ont
accompagné je suis très fier d'être mise
de la république
[Musique]